Okay. Today in the Times there was a
report of a clinical trial, which, uh,
event, that kind of thing
we talked about on Friday.
This was of of a, of a stat in which
is like Lipitor, it's a different one,
it's crest door, but they just
reported that a study of 18,000 people.
So a very big clinical trial, uh,
seemed to show that this, that uh,
it help it reduce the risk
of heart attack by a half,
uh, for people who didn't have high
cholesterol but had another risk.
This c reactive protein CRP.
And it said in the story this morning,
like many clinical trials,
the Jupiter study was sponsored by a
pharmaceutical company. In this case,
Astrazeneca,
it makes the drug in the trial receive
a stat and which is sold as crest door.
And then it says doctor Ridker
co-inventor have a CRP test,
said he first sought federal financing
for the study and was turned down.
He and other scientists interviewed for
this article except for doctrine able,
Dr. Gardner,
Dr. Wolfe have consulted for or received
research money from staton makers.
I guess I should say that
I've occasionally gotten
money from Staten makers too,
but not for this kind of thing. Uh, okay.
So That's interesting and relevant
to what we're talking about.
But specifically what we're
talking about now is nomenclature.
And last time we talked about
constitutional nomenclature,
the rules people made up for naming
the nature and sequence of bonds.
But since arrangement in
space is also important,
you have to be able to have
names for Stereo Chemistry.
And right now we're
interested in configurational
stereochemistry, the kind that,
uh, can only be changed
by breaking bonds, right?
Whereas as we'll see soon, conformational
changes don't require breaking bonds,
so typically are much easier to do.
So configurational isomers include the
tartaric acids that we've been speaking
about that have these physical properties.
Uh, one has a unique melting point,
the other two are the same,
but those two differ by the sign of the
optical rotation of polarized light.
So the first one is, is, uh, Misa.
Now how do we name these things?
One way is just to name them according
to the phenomenon, to what you observe.
So sometimes those,
those two tartaric acids that are
enantiomers mirror images of one another,
but not super imposable,
not super imposable,
sometimes they're referred
to as small D or small l,
which stands for Dextro or
Livo and means right or left.
And all it means is the direction they
rotate the plane of polarized light,
which you observe experimentally.
So there's nothing, uh,
more arcane about that.
Or you can say plus or minus,
meaning that they rotate light to the
right or rotate light to the left.
And those are absolutely the same thing,
right?
Dextro and plus Livo and minus.
Sometimes people use both names,
but they're redundant.
They both mean that rotates
light one way or the other.
So it just describes the phenomenon.
So there's nothing ambiguous about that.
It's a perfectly good name,
but it doesn't tell you what model you
should make to show it which mirror
images, which all you know is
which way it rotates light.
So that's phenomenal logical.
But there can be other names that have
to do with these Fisher projections.
We draw as to exactly which one is which.
So that one is clear enough that one has
a mirror image is its own mirror image.
There's a mirror that goes
through the middle of it.
So the top is the mirror image of the
bottom. It's mere image of itself.
And that one's clearly the Mezzo,
right? But how about the others?
One of them will look one
way and one the other,
but is there any fundamental thing that
we can understand that would tell us
which we'll rotate light to the right
and which will rotate light to the left.
And I'll tell you that I can say that.
And most people I know, in fact almost
everybody I know can't say that,
but there are a few people who think they
can say that and we'll hear about one
of them soon, now on Wednesday.
But anyhow, it's a question,
is it like should it be though those for
the right and the left handed the d and
the l or those, which one is which? Well,
uh,
Fisher decided that we'd just have to
have names for this and we have to be able
to draw pictures. So let's make
a guess as to which way it is.
And he devised a new,
uh, system of naming,
which doesn't depend on the
phenomenon but depends on genealogy.
That is synthesis.
You take a compound
like Glycerin Aldehyde,
which is small d and plus,
what does that mean?
DDI and plus for this,
there's a particular bottle of Palliser
Aldehyde which has that constitution,
right? And we're going to label it
d plus. And what does that mean?
Zach
rotates light to the right,
but we don't know exactly
how we should draw it, right?
Which the structure or its mirror image.
So,
and D and plus here, remember
our redundant, they joke
both just being at low.
Tate rotates light to the right,
but Fisher went further.
He defined that particular
glyceride Aldehyde as capital d.
There's a difference between
capital d and Small D.
Capital d is the names he used.
And that big Douglas or Aldehyde,
he guessed the one that
rotates light to the right.
He guests had that structure,
which when drawn with a Fischer
projection is that structure.
So that's just a guess. So we, this
is now gives us a starting point.
This Melissa Aldehyde,
which I'm going to call capital D
and I'm guessing has that structure.
I might be 100% wrong, right?
It might be the other one.
But let's just make this gas and then
we'll be able to talk about everything.
So what could you talk about?
You could do a multistep
synthesis in which the carbon,
the carbon is connected by the
arrows are the same carbon that is,
you redo the top half of the
molecule by doing chemical reactions.
The parts in Greek,
the part that's in green.
So Cho becomes that much
more complicated thing,
but you leave in tact
that carbon on the bottom.
So it's the same in tartaric acid
as it was in Douglas or Aldehyde,
whatever that was.
And we'll guess it's this one with the
Oah on the right is everybody with me,
with the guests he made.
So now if you could make that particular
tartaric acid isomer from d capital d
glycerin Aldehyde,
then you say that that's capital d
tartaric acid because you could
make it from Douglas or Aldehyde.
Any questions about that?
So it's just what you make for what if
you could make it from a d compound,
you call it a d compound, and the
mirror image would be the l compound,
Capitol Hill,
Claire
[inaudible],
just swapping policing the green squares,
the errors in them,
the swap,
the thing that's then the green square
on the bottom becomes the stuff in the
green square on the top.
Obviously you have to add another
carbon and you have to add a couple of
hydrogens and some more oxygens. So you
have to do some chemical transformations.
But the important thing is that the
thing of the top becomes the thing on the
top,
and the carbons connected by the
Arrow are precisely the same carbon.
Right. Okay. So that one, you know,
because you know where it came from
by genealogy, so that tartaric acid,
you'll call capital d according to Fisher,
but do you see a weakness
in this nomenclature scheme?
Yeah, sure. What is dependent
on your knowledge of this?
Well,
of course it could be 100% wrong.
Everything could be the mirror image
of what we thought it was right.
That's clearly a problem and that
was well recognized by Fisher,
but maybe I didn't understand your
question. Did I know that? That's okay.
Does anybody see another weakness?
Sam?
Capital d isn't very descriptive.
It's certainly not descriptive
of the structure accepted.
Unless you know what Douglas or
Aldehyde is, then it's descriptive,
but it's not descriptive alone.
It's only relative, right?
It's only relative to the Douglas or
Aldehyde and you have to know how that
relationship works.
Yeah.
For example,
someone else by go into lab and they want
to prepare tartaric acid from Douglas
or what might the other person do?
Lucas,
I can prepare it a different way.
So somebody else might put that carpet
into the one on the top and change the
brown ones.
Right.
There could be other transformations you
do that would change the carbon on the
bottom to the carbon on the bottom and
the carbon on the top is now the same as
the one on Glycerin Aldehyde, right?
In which case it would be exactly, uh,
that one on that one on the left would
be named capital d if you made it that
way. Everybody see the genealogy
would just be different.
Okay?
Okay.
So there's a fundamental problem here
that the capital d capital l designation
is ambiguous without having sub detailed
synthesis recipe or sub grievance that
people say, we'll always make things
this way rather than another way, right?
So it's not,
doesn't have meaning on its own.
You have to know exactly
how you [inaudible]
you made the transformation. So that's
a pretty cumbersome way to do names.
But that's what was done for 60
years, right? Those were the names,
capital d and capital l or sugars,
for example, for amino acids.
Okay?
And it's relative and it's
an it based on a guess.
But in 1950,
things changed because at 1950,
a man named by foot, uh, an x ray
crystallography for it. You tracked,
in fact working in the
van Hoff Laboratory,
the same building in which van Hoff did
the things in 1874 by foot determined
the crystal structure of
sodium rubidium salt. Remember,
they're two carboxylic
acids and tartaric acid.
So the sodium rubidium
assault of d small d,
capital l tartrate.
What does a small d mean,
Andrew?
It rotates the plane of polarized
light or twists it to the right.
And what does the capital l mean?
Alison said previously,
we said it resonated.
I couldn't hear very well previously.
It was,
we assumed that it would read
through. No, that's not true.
All right.
Maybe I didn't understand previously
what you love the model we you're just
talking about,
right?
It's what we've talked about with Fisher
that Pete was able to make this tar
tare Cason from l Glycerin Aldehyde from
the day where of what we talked about
before. So it was related
by that particular synthesis
to Elvis around Aldehyde.
So there's no conflict
between say, D and L, right?
It rotates light to the right.
That's the small one.
But it's geologically related
to El Glycerin Aldehyde. Okay.
But he was able to use a very special time
x-ray technique called
anomalous dispersion,
which we don't have time
to talk about right now,
but it was able to show exactly
which way the Adams were oriented.
And this is the picture he drew.
Right?
So clearly on the top is
seat seat two o's, right?
Carboxylate group on the
bottom of Carbox slate group.
The middle two carbons each have an
h and n o on them. The O is stippled,
so you'll see what it is and it's clear
the way he draws what's coming out,
why he drew at what's coming out
toward you and what's going back in.
Now here's a swat.
Fisher had guessed 60 years
before for El tartrate.
What he called El Tartrate was Fisher,
right or wrong.
How about the top carbon
that has o h on the H,
c o. H? Is it the same as
in, in the model that, uh,
that by foot published
is does it agree or not?
Yes, it agrees the Oah is coming
out towards you and to the right.
Same as in fishers. Picture of the
top carbon. Everybody got that?
How about the bottom of carbon?
The bottom carbon Fisher has go into
the left and by foot has it go into the
right. This one here, right?
That's going to the right from this
carbon Fisher's drawing it to the left.
Did they disagree?
Who said something?
Do they agree or disagree
that funny you say?
Uh,
what does Fisher means by this bond here?
The CH bond,
which isn't going out toward you.
The H or back in,
okay.
The official projection,
which is shown here.
It's got vertical bonds and horizontal
bonds. Which one is coming out for you?
From the carbon.
Okay. Somebody else? Uh, yeah. Hey,
which bonds?
Bonds?
The carbon carbon bonds are going into
the board. That's Fisher's convention.
Yeah,
because I trusted them and
so that everybody knows.
Yeah. So these two are coming out on the
board. How about in by floods? Picture
for the second car. The second
department. Here's the first one.
Here's the second one.
Aha.
So to make it like fish or you have to
rotate it so they're coming out of the
board. So in fact, they do
agree, right? It's just that, uh,
by foot is made realistically and,
and uh,
and fissures was made with these rubber
tubing bonds and you had the bend it to
get it that way. But it's the same
configuration. So Fisher was right.
So these structures
cheers that had been drawn for 60 years.
We're drawn. Right. They could have,
it was a 50 50 chance that it could
have been the other way around,
but thank God he was right so we don't
have to go back and correct everything
and then know whether things were
written before 1950 or after 1950
yeah.
You'll just the LSP,
that's like each bed.
Is John me out of the door?
Does that go back?
Okay. If you rotate this molecule by
180 degrees around the vertical axis,
then this carbon with respect to
the carbon we're interested in here,
this carbon will be going back
into the board and this carpenter,
we're going back into the board.
That's the way these are, right?
But in the process, that
rotation, this, Ooh,
that was back into the right after a 180
degree rotation about the vertical axis
will be out in front and to the left,
which is the way it's drawn
in the Fisher project.
It would be good that,
oh yeah, but you don't care. This is
just a show that couldn't configuration.
Right. When you do that rotation. Yeah,
these will, these will do the other.
But the point is that Fisher structure
was right with respect to each carbon
about what's going, which way, which
tetrahedron it is. Okay. So that's fine.
And then by foot wrote are
in the same paper he wrote.
The question of nomenclature is
beyond the scope of our investigation.
He's just doing the x ray
to find out which way it is.
The problem of nomenclature now
concerns given confirmations.
Now you know which one it is you want
to show and requires a notation which
denotes these configurations in
an unambiguous and if possible,
self explanatory way.
So you don't need to know how
it was synthesized or anything.
Now you know how it really is,
right?
What name are you going to give to it
so people can know just from the name
which way it is.
Now this is related to the idea of naming
configurations involving double bonds.
So we're going to first
show you how you do that,
which actually came second and then
we'll go back to see how they named the
configuration at a tetrahedral
carbon. So malic acid from, from uh,
apples has that structure shown.
And if you heat it,
you lose water and get a double bond.
But you get two isomers
mallaig and few Merrick acids.
And you'll remember we showed that
before that Vantiff made those with his
models.
And one of them has the two coh is near
one another and one has the farther from
one another and we can draw them that
way as well near on the left and far on
the right.
And if you heat these molecules further,
the one on the left can lose water and
foreman and hydride but not the one on
the right.
Why not the one on the right?
It's pretty obvious, Russell,
they're too far apart.
So you know which one
they're close together
and which one they're far apart.
So that experiment proves which is switch,
it's not as hard as the case of the right
and left hand where you had to do this
very special ex-ray technique.
So it was known that maleic acid was
the one that can form an anhydrite and
therefore it had him on the same side.
And that was called sis,
meaning on this side of,
and the other one was called trans across.
So that was a perfectly good
nomenclature for these two isomers of the
dehydrated malic acid.
Maleic was sis and fumaric acid was trans.
So these names were used
for a very long time,
but they weren't really good names.
And the reason you can see by
looking at this molecule is this one,
would you call it CIS or trans?
Same side or opposite side.
Andrew, what do you say next day, Andrew?
This is our nomenclature problem.
Would you call it trans?
You say
this one here.
Why?
Because the ch three is are next
to one another. So you might,
Paul insist on the other end if you want
it to say how this ad is related to the
acid, you'd say it's trans,
right? So that means it's the,
as an absolute
naming nomenclature,
it's very hard to generalize this
because you have to know which one you're
picking to say it's CIS or trans.
It's fine to talk about the
relative configuration to
say the methyl on the left
is sis to the methyl on the right or to
say the methyl on the left is trans to
the COO.
H that's fine.
But as a as to whether to say the
molecule itself is cis or trans,
you have to know which one you're
talking about on the right.
So that's another thing where you,
you're going to have to have
some convention or something.
And the way people
decided to do it was this,
you assign the groups at each end,
took one end,
and then the other end of the
double bond and assign priority.
So you say we're going to give higher
priority to one group or the other and
that's the one we're
going to use for the name.
So on what basis might you
assign a priority to a group?
Say which group has higher priority?
C h three or h,
which one do you think should have
higher priority? C H three. Okay.
How about on this n c h three or Coa,
which should have higher priority.
Why? It's heavier. Okay.
Now let's think about how that,
how that was gonna work out.
So we'll assign of by atomic
number or atomic weight.
If we have two that are different
isotopes of one another, right?
But we won't,
we won't sell up the atomic numbers of
all the groups that are in that. That is,
we want some up c and o
and o and h and c and d,
three H's.
Why not sum them all up and then
see which one has higher total atomic
number. What's wrong with that?
Perfectly well defined.
It's tedious.
It's cumbersome to have to add it all up.
So what you,
what rule are you going to do?
You'll go until you find a difference.
Go out until you find a difference.
Once you find a difference, you stop. So
you don't have to go everywhere. Okay?
So at the first difference,
the same as we said with numbering
last time, right? Okay. So on the left,
in each case you have a carbon compared
to a hydrogen is the thing that's
immediately attached.
Carbon has higher priority,
higher atomic number on the right.
It,
it begins with the Thai.
Incidentally,
we're going to have to deal with
double bonds, Coh and provato. Right?
The way you do it just by convention,
there's nothing,
God didn't write this on the tablets,
right?
It's you just pretend that there are two,
two of those atoms.
When there's a double
bond, just pretend. Okay,
so now we compare the top of the
bottle. If we go to the, the first step,
it's carbon versus carbon.
It's a tie.
So we're going to have to go further.
Why don't we go to the next level?
We see on the left it's
oxygen versus hydrogen, right?
And oxygen is higher.
We don't have to go any further.
We found a difference so forget
the rest of it. Everybody with me?
Okay,
so we say we might say the one on the
left is trans and the one on the right is
sis.
However,
people for 60 years or longer in this
case have been used in the name CIS and
Trans to mean one thing or another
and sometimes will agree with them and
sometimes we don't,
which is going to cause great confusion
as to whether you're using a pre 1950
name or a post 1950 name and at least
half the compounds are going to be wrong.
Right.
So the names trans insists that have
been polluted by previous usage.
So we're going to have to have new
names. Yeah, Lucas [inaudible],
you've mural duplicate all those as well.
Okay.
Okay. So this one was used with a German
root cause. The guys from Switzerland,
we're doing this and Gagan which means
a posed and the one on the right,
so it's e when they're trans,
when they're opposite one another,
and when they're adjacent to one another,
it's called together Suzanne Z.
I've always thought this is a real pity
that it wasn't the other way around.
So I hope this doesn't confuse you because
these are on the same side and these
are on
opposite sides. Right. But
it's just backwards from that.
So just to remember that it's unfortunate.
Okay,
so z beads together and he means apart.
that's the name we use for there. Okay.
Now notice that in assigning priority,
as we said, just to Belabor this a little
bit, you proceed one shell at a time,
so,
so we saw a tie when it was carbon versus
carbon and when it was three oxygens
versus three hydrogens,
it was obvious that the top wins,
but now let's go to this case.
Okay,
now carbon versus carbon,
that's a tie. We go out further.
Three oxygens beat a carbon
and two hydrogens, right?
But there's chlorine
is on the bottom right?
The chlorine is really high priority,
right?
But it's irrelevant because the
decision has already been made.
So you respect earlier decisions,
right?
You only go as far as you need
to go to see a difference. Okay.
I think we've said that enough.
Now these are the guys that invented
the scheme to name handedness, the,
it's called the CIP priority scheme and
the C is our s con and the eye is CK in
gold.
Both of them are from Britain.
And the P is a lot of mere
prayer log who's in Switzerland,
although he's a native of, uh, Yugoslavia.
Now, uh, these were many people,
particularly synthetic chemists would
consider Robert Robinson and RB Woodward,
the greatest Chem organic
chemists of the 20th century. Uh,
they both thought they were probably
the greatest individual one. Right.
So I love this picture taken by Jack
Roberts of them at a seminar at MIT around
this same time, uh, because they sort
of aren't looking at one another. Right?
What's Robinson looking at?
Robinson is looking at in gold who'd
be really despised and vice versa.
Right? There was no love lost
between in gold and, and Robinson.
Uh,
and this is illustrated by an account
that pray log gave in his autobiography,
he encountered, uh, Robinson
in the airport in Zurich.
Robinson was on his way to a
meeting in Israel. Robinson.
Hello Kucharski what are you
doing here in Zurich? Pray Log.
Excuse me, Sir Robert. I am
only pray log. I live here.
He got a Nobel prize to pray log.
I'm only pray log and I live here.
Robinson,
you know,
pray log your an in gold's
configurational notation is all wrong.
Pray Long, sir. Robert. It can't
be wrong. It's just the convention.
You either accept it or not.
Well then if it's not wrong, it's
absolutely unnecessary. Okay?
So anyhow, it's the point of this
slide is that it's a convention.
There's not right and wrong about it.
It's that they proposed rules and that's,
those are the rules that
people have adopted.
And that's how you give a name to the
absolute configuration of a stereo Magenic
carbon.
And for fun for Wednesday,
you can try this exercise
going back to this, uh,
this medieval manuscript and using
the figures in it to devise your own
convention to describe Kira Allity.
So you can put yourself in the
position of con in gold and pray log.
Okay,
so here's the con in gold.
Pray Log s nomenclature scheme
for stereo genic centers.
First you have to decide
on each of these carbons,
which are mirror images you see of one
another, which Adams have which priority.
So let's start on the left.
What's the highest priority for a
substituent on the central carbon?
Therefore groups,
which has the highest priority?
Which one? Sorry. Oh,
h o o is the highest atomic number.
What's the lowest
h? Right? Uh, there's also a d there.
So same atomic number,
hydrogen and deuterium.
Which one should be higher? Deuterium?
Tyrians heavier. If it's isotopes,
you take the heavier one.
Okay. So here's one, four,
three, two, right?
That's the priorities and
analogously on the right.
And now we have to decide whether
there, which one to call, right?
And which one to call left.
And the way you do it,
one way of doing it is to take a,
a thing like this where I have uh,
these uh, red, yellow, green, blue,
red, orange, yellow, green,
blue, right? The order of the
spectrum, red, yellow, green,
blue. And I make a spiral
that connects them like that.
And now is that conventionally what
you call a right handed or left hand in
spiral? You know, if you look
at it, if I turned it like this,
it would move this way,
right?
So screws are called right
handed and left handed screws.
And the reason is that the,
that the or the, you know,
toe bone connected to the
foot bone kind of thing,
the way your arm is put together
for right handed people,
it's easier to drive a screw like this,
right?
So that's conventionally called
her right hand and screw.
So this you would call right handed,
okay?
Now if you can't remember from how to
turn a screwdriver, uh, you can look at,
you can do
this trick with your hand.
You put your thumb along the direction
of the lowest priority hydrogen in this
case. So it's coming out of the board,
right? And you curl your fingers,
right? And you notice it goes
one, two, three, and then four.
So that one on the left, his left hand
that everybody, see how I did that?
Curl your fingers. They go
one, two, three, four. Okay,
so that's a lefthanded one. The one on
the right, if you, you do it this way,
you put that, so that's,
and you call it not left.
You call it ass for the Latin sinister.
So it's not going to get
confused with D and l.
And so on that have already been used.
It's a new way of doing it.
So that was s and the one on the right,
if I put my thumb,
so it goes back toward
the h and curl my fingers.
I go from one to two to three.
Okay,
so that one is called r
four rectus Latin for right.
Okay. Now there's another there.
There are lots of tricks to do this.
If you don't like you doing it that
way, you can do it this way. Uh,
pretend that this is a steering wheel
of a car and the h is going back in.
All right? So here on
this one, on the right,
I'm sitting here driving the car like
this and the h is going away from me.
Everybody got that? And I noticed
that I go one, two, three,
right? That's going to turn the car
to the right. Everybody see that?
So this one will turn the car to the left.
If I,
if I turn the wheel to
go from oh to C to d,
okay? So that one's a left turn
and that one's a right turn.
So whatever works for you is fine.
And I can assure you that on some tests
I'm going to look out and see people
with their papers there and
so on. And they're going to
be going like this, right?
How's, that's a handy way
to do it. Handy. Okay, so,
so let's try it on tartaric acid here.
Let's do the top carbon of tartaric acid.
Okay?
So we've got to decide on the priority
of the groups here. Here's one group,
another group, another group, another
group, which is the highest priority.
Oh, H is the highest,
right? Oh, as the highest.
Now we've got two carbons that are tied.
Which one's gonna win top or bottom?
W pop. You sayK , five
times
three oxygens.
And only one oxygen. Right? So the one
on the top has ox, not, not more oxygens,
but it's got the oxygen's nearer.
Okay? So we don't have to go as far.
So this is going to be one,
two, three, four. Okay?
Now let me see your hands. Operating. Put,
put a farm along with the age,
the direction the h goes
and curl your hands.
One right top. Bottom one, two, three.
And tell me whether that's
right or left handed.
Okay.
How many big collapse?
How many think rice is a democracy? The
right have, but they're also correct.
Okay.
That was one or two or three
that it's right handed.
And the bottom ones also right handed her.
What is,
I have to take a lot of time to have
you do this. To do the bottom one.
Why does the bottom one follow
if you know the top one?
Because you can rotate the thing 180
degrees and it's the same and that will
change the top end of the bottom.
So whatever the top is,
the bottom is the same thing.
So the name of this is in parentheses
to our carbon two is our carbon three is
also are then dash two three dihydroxy
dihydroxy butane dial awake acid.
Okay. So now we have a steam that does
that and not as, this is the, uh, the,
the uh, gate into the new chemistry
building just up the prospect street.
And it's got things that,
that relate to the different
branches of chemistry on it.
And this one is those carbon tetra heater
with the spiral on it that says which
handedness it is. They're both
right and left handed once there.
Okay. Now, Ras advisor [inaudible].
If you start with a molecule,
which maybe you've gotten from [inaudible]
nature,
that's all one hand like lactic
acid from milk are lactic acid.
There are processes which converted
into a 50 50 mixture of our and Das.
For example. Suppose you had a base
and it could pull off a hydrogen.
What hydrogen would it pull
off from this molecule of base?
Any idea?
What is the most reactive group here
or another way of saying this is a high
homo. What's the low Lumo going to be?
Well, there's several low lumos.
There's the COO double bond. Pi Star.
That's a good one, right? However, it
won't get you any places you put it on,
come off again. Okay. Or there's
Sigma Star. Oh, age here,
but there's also a
sigma star. Oh, a chair.
But this one's better because it's next
to the, to the Pi Star, right, so this is,
that's why it's called an acid.
You already knew that and you could lose
the h plus and get down to this. Okay.
And that'll go on off, on,
off, on off, long time. That's
fine. Nothing special there.
But once in a long while,
that's easy to do.
Once in a long while you might
pull off the wrong hydrogen.
You might pull off this one.
All right.
So that's not nearly as easy.
But what had happens,
it's interesting for two reasons.
One is it's not as bad as you might've
thought because it's adjacent to this Pi
Star,
which means that the vacant orbital
here can stabilize those that high homo,
which means you can draw that resonance
structure with a double bond there.
So it's hard,
but it's not as hard as it might
be once in a while that'll happen.
And usually it'll go back again.
Right.
But what's especially interesting,
oh, well, just as a footnote,
it's possible to pull both of them off.
But that would be very
unusual to make a Diane ion,
which is high in energy because you're
putting so many electrons close to one
another.
Okay.
But what's relevant for our purposes
is it that molecule is plainer.
So it's not handed.
This one had a car apartment.
This one had a chiral carbon in it,
but this one doesn't have an asymmetric
carbon. Aye. Aye. Stereo genic carbon.
So this one is the one in the
middle is neither right nor left.
So if you go from right to
something that isn't right or left,
you can come back,
put the hydrogen ion,
the hydrogen comes from
the front of the screen,
goes on to where the minus charges
and you're back to the left.
But the hydrogen could have come from
the back of the screen at the same carbon
and that would give the one on the
right and would be s lactic acid.
So after a long time of heating with base,
you can take one that's all r
and have it become 50 50 rns.
And that process is called
Rassam. Ization. Why would
it be called Rassam? Ization.
Yeah,
cause it makes a receiving mixture of 50
50 mixture from something that was pure.
Okay. That's interesting. But what,
what may be more interesting is,
oh,
well this is just a footnote on that.
If you here to go from our,
our tartaric acid to Bizo tartaric acid,
you change just one such hydrogen.
The one here has been taken off and put
back on the other side to give that one.
So that's not rationalization.
You're not going to a 50 50
mixture of the two hands, right?
So it has a different name.
It's called the Pim as Asian.
That's just for vocabulary.
But what's more interesting
than rationalization is
the reverse does start with
a 50 50 mixture and go to all one.
And that's the main subject for the rest
of what we're going to be talking about,
uh, before the exam. Okay. So,
so you start with Rs and you separate
it into R and s in separate vials.
So you have just the
one you want. Okay. One
way we've already seen him doing that
was pastor a conglomerate is a mixture of
crystals were each crystal is all one
hand or all the other hand when it's a 50
50 mixture of such crystals.
So there's no net handedness to it,
right? But then if you can, if
you have a situation like that,
notice you wouldn't have that.
If the crystals had a right
handed molecule and then
I'll lefthanded and that a
right handed and then a lefthanded,
you couldn't pick it apart because you
can't separate one molecule from another.
Right?
But if all the crystals are right handed
and some crystals are all lefthanded,
right,
then in principle you can pick them apart
and that's what precisely what posture
did when he noticed it.
Right?
So you can separate them and there are
tricks that can help you do it even
better or more easily.
When the crystals,
when the things crystallizes all right
handed or left all lefthanded one is to
start with molecules in solution and have
only one form crystallize and have the
other one stay in solution, then all
you have to do is filter it. Okay,
and how can you do that?
It's because,
and chiral resolve poison is another one
which will keep one form from growing
so that only one form crystallizes.
How do you do that? Here's a crystal,
which is in solution.
And suppose that's exactly at equilibrium.
So it neither dissolves nor nor a nor
crystallizes exactly at equilibrium.
It's saturated.
Okay.
Now the interior molecules and the
crystal are very stable because they have
exactly the right environment,
right there are more stable
than the ones in solution.
The ones on the surface are not so stable
cause they don't have the neighbors,
all the neighbors they need.
Right.
But the average molecule is
exactly the savers in solution.
So it just sits there.
It's at equilibrium with solution now.
So that's the situation we have.
That's the temperature and concentration.
So that this crystal is exactly
at Equilibria with solution.
Now suppose that you
had a smaller crystal,
would it also be at
equilibrium with solution
if it were smaller or do
you see any difference?
The smaller one has a higher
fraction of molecules on the surface.
Okay.
What does that mean?
Yeah.
The molecules on the surface are
less stable than the ones in side.
If the average molecule here is precisely
the same as the ones in solution.
So it just sits there.
How about this one?
The average molecule is less
stable than the ones in solution.
So what will it do?
It'll dissolve. Okay, so
a small one dissolves.
This one just sits here. How
about, uh, so that'll go away.
How about, and so as time goes on, it gets
smaller and smaller. The phases move in.
How about this one?
What will it do?
It will grow because it's more
stable in solution, right?
Bingo.
So that one grows as small one said,
this one in the middle is
called the Ismeta stable.
We defined it as being stable
is just sitting there. Right?
But it's not a stable.
If it gets any smaller,
it'll shrink if it gets any
large rental grow. Right?
So you have to get a crystal that size
called the critical size before the
crystal will grow.
Right?
So this suggests a way of
getting only one form to grow.
You have a solution, it's
receiving 50 50. Right?
But there are no crystals in
there that are big enough to grow.
Can you see what you can do?
You add a little fairy dust,
right?
Powdered crystal of one of the two forms,
but have them be big enough to grow.
So only those will grow and then you can
filter it and you have just that one.
And that's done industrially as a way
of getting just one form to separate the
two forms of means of resolution.
Okay.
And the other way is to add a poison
that will absorb on one and keep it from
growing.
Okay?
So that's one way that's actually used
industrially as well as in the lab.
Another way is to form
temporary Daya Steria Mers.
Because remember the right and
the left are mirror images.
So almost all their properties in
the same like their solubility, okay.
But suppose you put something
else with it like uh,
here, uh, let's shake hands.
Josh care. Does that feel
normal? Feels weird, right?
That feels good. So write with right is
different from right with left, right?
It's a different property,
okay?
So if what I did was make dayas theoria
is by adding something else to these
molecules,
which itself is only one hand.
Like right now all have
things that reacted that are
right with right and things
that are reactive right with left.
And what's the relationship
between those new things?
Are they enantiomers right with right,
right with left and now I'm comparing
rr with Rs. What's the relation?
Are they mirror images? No, they're
not married. They're just different,
different solubility, different boiling
point. Everything will be different.
Different reactivity. Right. So on the
basis of that, I can separate them,
but if I did it in such
a way that now I can
remove that thing I added now after the
separation I can go back and have the
original things separated.
Okay.
So temporary Daya steric there's
one way to do it as chromatography.
So the stuff that I put in the
chromatography column can be all one hand.
I've put the new stuff on,
I put that's the packing of the column.
I now run stuff through it.
One absorbs more strongly than
the other doesn't move as fast.
So one will come out the
bottom of the column faster.
That's one way of making temporary
dietary verse or making a compound with a
chiral resolved. Mate. Okay. For example,
this Alinia compound that we saw before,
that was that proved fan it off was right.
This is how it was actually resolved,
how it was separated.
So it says at the top they used alkaloids.
And alkaloid is an organic base,
isolated from plants and the
plants made only one hand of it.
And so you use it to make a Daya Steri,
Americ salt with the receiving mixture
of right and left handed acids.
So now you have two salts, right? Right,
salt and right left salt and they'll
have different solubilities and you can
crystallize. So here's what
happened. There's Bruce scene,
that's one of these alkaloids and
you'll see it has all those centers,
stereo genic centers. So it's Chiral just
one hand, cause she got it from nature.
And now you mix 4.7 grams
of the acid in five,
two grams of Bruce scene, which means
that they're at about a one to one ratio.
So you have both salts there and
now you, uh, you crystallize,
you get a solid salt and
you weighed four grams,
which means you've got 42% yield,
right?
About half of the stuff out and
at that stuff, then you, uh,
had you recrystallize it
to make sure it's pure,
that salt you've got out melting point
didn't change. It was already pure.
Liberate the acid by shaking it
with hydrochloric acid and ether.
Now you've got the acid and it melted 145
to 146 and it's rotation was plus 29.5
degrees and recrystallize
and didn't change it.
It was pure and it turns out that the
other one is melts one 44 to one 46
degrees and is so same
melting point essentially,
but exactly the opposite rotation.
So they manage the separation by making
salts that were Daya Steria Merrick,
so they had different solubility
and then take the salts apart again.
And pastor figured a way of doing this,
uh,
in this story,
which I suspect is not a true story.
Now I'm going to stop here,
but we're going to have mostly what's on
Wednesday's lecture is not going to be
on the exam,
but there's a little more here that I'm
probably going to make available for the
exam that I'll talk about on Wednesday,
and I'll have to think over just
how much more it's going to be.
Not Too much more probably. Okay,
so we'll see you on Wednesday.
Most of what's on Wednesday
won't be on the exam.